- Moi, je ne suis jamais
allé à New York.
- Il n'y a rien à New York
qu'il n'y a pas à Chicago, à
part du monde qui court partout.
- Pour la première fois au
Québec, un théâtre institutionel
présente une pièce mettant en
vedette presque exclusivement
des comédiens noirs.
FRÉDÉRIC PIERRE, comédien
- Je ne pensais pas avoir ça
de mon vivant, je pense.
Je ne pensais surtout pas en
fait qu'on monterait
un classique afro-américain,
une pièce noire.
- "Héritage" est un classique du
théâtre américain et la première
pièce d'une autrice noire jouée
sur Broadway.
TRACY MARCELIN, comédienne
- Les personnages
de cette pièce-là sont...
comme elle a dit, sont riches,
sont complexes, sont...
sont beaux dans...
- Dans leur imperfection...
- Puis c'est un texte
excessivement touchant, en fait.
- On se calme, ce n'est qu'un
chèque.
- Ouvrez-la!
- La pièce raconte l'histoire
d'une famille qui se déchire
autour d'un héritage.
MYRIAM DE VERGER, Comédienne
- En fait la pièce, c'est
vraiment comme un genre de
Belles soeurs. On le compare ici
à notre Belles Soeurs
de Michel Tremblay.
Donc, c'est vraiment
de s'identifier à une famille
qui s'aime, qui vit toutes sorte
de hauts et de bas, donc
n'importe qui, pas juste
des personnes noires,
racisées, peut s'identifier
aux personnages.
- Signe qu'un an après
la controverse qui a entouré
les spectacles "Slàv"
et "Kanata", les choses
changent.
- Moi, je suis arrivée à une
époque où est-ce que la question
sur la représentativité ethnique
n'était pas encore à la mode.
Là, les acteurs ethniques ou
enfin, les acteurs racisés
vont pouvoir vraiment prendre
leur place puis s'émanciper
complètement en tant qu'artiste.
- Pourquoi vous pensez toujours
qu'il y a une autre femme
dès qu'un homme se cherche!
- La troupe espère attirer un
nouveau public au théâtre et
même susciter des vocations.
- J'ai décidé de faire ce métier
là dans la salle chez Duceppe
quand j'avais 13 ans, à peu
près. Mes parents étaient
abonnés, ils nous avaient
amenés. Moi, c'est en voyant
du théâtre que j'ai...
Puis même si j'étais pas
représenté en terme de couleur,
c'est pas important.
J'ai eu cette envie-là.
Si "Héritage" pouvait donner
soif à une jeune génération dite
de la diversité de s'intéresser
au théâtre et aux arts
de la scène, ça, ce serait
misson accomplie.
- C'est le temps de crier haut
et fort alléluia!
- Ici Nabi-Alexandre Chartier, Radio-Canada, Montréal